helicopters from the navy coast guard
and other agencies are flying rescue
missions along the texas gulf coast this
morning two navy amphibious ships and a
unit of marines will head to the region
today from virginia omar villafranca is
in college station texas he saw some of
the helicopter rescues firsthand omar
good morning
what you hear behind me right now is
helicopter sea combat squadron 7 getting
ready for another mission we were with
the navy search and rescue team and we
went more than 150 miles to port arthur
texas and we were there when they
started pulling desperate texans from
the water
for hundreds of texans stranded in
rising water the path to safety has been
this a lifeline from the air helicopter
rescue crews are able to pluck residents
from rooftops and raging rivers in five
hours the team we flew it pulled eight
people and even a dog to safety from
hard hit port arthur well honestly i
haven't really seen anything like that
before lieutenant anthony arrow was a
pilot on one of those missions if you
want to be rescued what should they do
so a pilot can recognize it so we're
kind of looking for like a two-hand kind
of wave like this or anything white a
help sign really anything out of the
ordinary it's a careful coordination
between pilot and crew to locate and
load people desperate to escape a toxic
brew of flood water left by tropical
storm harvey people that are coming up
are telling us that the water is cold
they've been sitting in maybe two to
three feet of water for a very long time
one of the first rescues that came up
was an older woman she wasn't able to
get her medication but her son-in-law
who was also rescued was able to grab
her bible and he said we're going to
need it so far this team has flown over
40 missions with more than 250 rescues
one of those who was rescued was this 93
year old woman she was pulled to safety
by petty officer joe snyder he told us
part of the mission is helping calm
people who are frightened and desperate
good feeling to have knowing that you're
this person's only hope pretty much you
showed up with justin and nick over time
these rescue swimmers are trained for
the churning waters of the open seas so
this is a very different mission for
them they cannot wear flippers when they
go in the water they have to wear boots
to protect themselves from whatever
debris may be in the water one rescue
swimmer told me he thought his first
rescue mission would be in a war zone
not at home
maurice okay omar so impressive thank
you